tens of thousands of people have
gathered in the Czech Republic's capital
Prague to demand the resignation of
Prime Minister Andrei Babak opponents of
bhavish accused the populist leader of
profiting from his office and conflicts
of interest he's one of the Czech
Republic's richest men the protests
coincide with events commemorating the
start of the 1989 velvet revolution that
toppled the communist regime in what was
then Czechoslovakia organizers say they
want the Czech Republic to rediscover
the pro-democracy ideals that fuel the
protest 30 years ago standing by for us
in Prague is DW correspondent Jonathan
crane Jonathan good to see you tell us
what is happening where you are right
now well this is the latest in a series
of protests organized by the activist
group million moments for democracy and
initially estimates to suggest that this
is by far the biggest but they've held
so far surpassing the quarter million
that came to let nur just behind me in
June now as you say this coincides with
the anniversary of the Velvet Revolution
the fall of communism in then
Czechoslovakia and that fact hasn't been
lost on the protesters here the people
we've spoken to say this isn't just
about fighting corruption this isn't
just about demanding the resignation of
the Prime Minister Andrei barbash it's
about not taking for granted all those
hard freedoms liberal democracy that was
fought so hard for 30 years ago now
barbash has drawn comparisons with
Donald Trump in the u.s. a barbash leads
a populist party he is a very rich
businessman as you say and he's accused
of being in conflict of interest because
as well as being the Prime Minister his
businesses are though in a trust front
people say he is still benefiting and
using his position as prime minister to
further those business interests now
earlier I did speak to one of the
protest leaders Benjamin roll and he
explained to me why people have come out
today well the main idea behind million
moments for democracy is the activation
of civil society and to make people to
realize that every single one of us has
responsibility and we can do something
and
change our way of thinking and change
even the politics alright it was some
very lofty goals there this young man
says he wants to change check politics
but Jonathan what exactly does he mean
by that well they said that they've
offered the Prime Minister and ultimatum
either he gives up his conflicts of
interests he resigns or they will
continue to protest and up the ante now
I think they would be the first to admit
that regime change is not going to
happen just like that because barbash is
very very popular still his party is
polling at 30% by far the most popular
party in the country and if you go
outside of Prague in the regions where
he's wooed older voters with promises of
more money more money in their pension
you know the party is still very popular
tie to that the opposition is quite
fragmented quite ineffective so there's
nobody really to challenge him even his
coalition partners of Social Democrats
won't walk out on the coalition because
they know they would face an electoral
obscurity so it is still going to be
very difficult for the prime minister to
go anywhere I think protesting is one
thing but regime change is probably
quite another
GW correspondent Jonathan crane
reporting for us from Prague the Czech
capital we thank you very much